every indication is that an endorsement
of Hillary Clinton by Bernie Sanders is
coming very very soon and indeed senator
Bernie Sanders today acknowledged what
has already been widely reported which
is that tomorrow he is going to be
joining the presumptive Democratic
nominee Hillary Clinton on the campaign
trail in New Hampshire are the Bernie
supporters ready to stop talking about
paths to victory and I don't ask this in
any kind of demeaning way my facebook
stream Louis is filled with long posts
from friends saying it isn't over here
is how it's going to happen there is how
it's going to happen I truly do not get
it and hear every indication that
although we have not yet seen an
endorsement we will see one soon
typically Louis if you're still running
a campaign you don't show up to rally
for the other candidates do no no not
usually I've been seeing Facebook post
saying that they've the stories about
Bernie endorsing Hillary are hoaxes and
uh that the Bernie er Buster's are still
at it yeah uh and that's fine i guess uh
if do you not doing any harm really but
know about my concern is at some point a
disconnection from reality will become
problematic right in some way shape or
form at some point reality is going to
have to set in and they're going to have
to be some real serious uh
considerations made 90 after a video
saying Bernie Bernie or bust while
understandable doesn't make practical
sense we received a ton of hate for it
and I stand by everything we said there
Louis no doubt about it at let me be
clear as someone who voted for Bernie
Sanders here in Massachusetts and feels
that Hillary Clinton is not progressive
enough I still received hate for that
video and I believe everything we said
in the video made practical sense and
well that they're somewhat fanatic but
uh the that convention is going to
happen yeah we're going to have a
nominee right and then there will be two
choices it most likely uh you you will
have to your what will they decide well
they're not to vote or to vote for
Hillary well this is the two choices
things
were saying Bernie's a hypocrite right
Jill Stein from the Green Party has
offered Bernie Sanders said she would be
open to stepping down as the Green Party
nominee and letting Bernie Sanders take
that over and that he should be doing
that instead of going out there and
campaigning with Hillary hammer Sanders
Bernie Sanders taking over the Green
Party nomination potentially gives the
election to Donald Trump hate me for it
I don't care how can i buy into the
two-party blah blah blah I know the
emails all get trust me it's July of
2016 if Bernie Sanders joins the Green
Party today Donald Trump's chances of
being the next president jump
dramatically and if I'm Bernie Sanders
do I want to be responsible for that I'm
not if at Bernie Sanders is not the burn
it all down so in 4 8 16 20 24 years we
can rebuild that is not the Bernie
Sanders approach so if you're angry with
Bernie for that approach go to it but
that it would be utter disaster yeah it
seems like there are two types of voters
the voters who vote uh and make a
decision so that they can feel good
about themselves right and the voters
who think about the the macro and the
bigger picture and and vote to uh yeah
you know logically if you want a better
path forward we need Instant Runoff
voting that is the system that would
allow you to show up and say okay
Bernie's running third party my first
choice is Bernie Sanders if after the
first tally is done Bernie Sanders does
not have a plurality of votes then my
vote goes to Hillary Clinton and this is
a system which we have talked about many
times which party insiders do not want
for obvious reasons that would alleviate
not all but many of the issues that our
current system has